today's topic so as you may remember I
came out as last year and since then I
have been dating women and what I found
very fascinating is that the more I date
women the more I find myself
understanding men let me explain exhibit
a I was on a first date with a girl who
asked me out by the way this is relevant
because when the check came she never
once made a move to pay not even like
the fake let me reach for my purse move
and though I don't mind paying on a date
part of me felt like you know the offer
would have been nice I was also a little
taken aback that she didn't even say
thank you and I never heard from her
again it really made me feel like she
just asked me out so she could have a
free dinner and the moment I thought
that I was like oh my god I sound like
all of my guy friends right now
and my argument against why guys should
pay for dates has always been like look
girls take hours to get ready our
investment is looking really nice for
you make up clothes that costs money too
but we were both girls in this situation
we both took hours to get ready so I
definitely felt slighted well I didn't
ask you to get ready
you get ready because you want to get
ready that's you I just think it's
interesting do you know how they say
like someone complements a woman we
should walking down the street and then
the guy and the woman gets mad the guy's
a little late why do you make yourself
look so fancy because you want a
compliment right and the woman replied
well I've got ready for me I don't look
good for you
I don't want your compliments I just
think it's interesting now it's like I
put an effort to look good but now you
got to pay for it oh I don't have to pay
for it I have to pay for you to look
good you come as you are
I said this rhetoric is really weird
that's not an argument you look good for
you then we can't take that for
accountability yeah and then don't men
don't make an effort to look good we
don't work out you don't put in effort
to buy nice clothes the shower perfume
cologne we don't all that good shot well
we're just like we just came out the
cave when we showed up and we beat the
table we're like give us some poom poom
trade up from the basketball practice
right there date and because that that's
why you guys deserve to not have to pay
on dates again it really just sounds
like picking and choosing what you want
to bet it not you know what I mean and a
lot of you a couple of conversation with
feminists they were saying yeah this is
that Michael kibbles if you go on a date
do you pay or you share it a couple of
them were saying need to chair it they
don't mind
Gaza that was the minority most most of
them were like well you know I still
enjoy you know and I'm like oh girl hmm
what's wrong with selective equality
exhibit be on another date I went back
to a girl's house and I ended up making
friends with her cat that's not a pun
I'm talking about her literal actual
animal and she said oh my cat never
likes anyone
I better go out and buy a wedding dress
[Laughter]
and again I felt like I got some serious
perspective I have been guilty of making
these kinds of jokes on dates with men I
never really thought anything of it I
was a big filly but then when I was on
the receiving end of it I suddenly
understood the panic it is but it's not
sometimes people reveal what they want
to think about you based off little
comments that are out of place if I'm
getting along with your cat you don't
come out like you'd make a great husband
yeah I'm saying there's like sometimes
you go I'll be like oh you can cook you
gonna make a great boyfriend it's the
first date I'm just like okay first time
is fine but then when you hear like two
three times afterwards like okay I see
where this is going
you're trying to implant that idea in my
brain so that it stays there it's
interests yes to date women to
understand this
and finally Exhibit C one girl invited
me back into her house and her specific
words were do you want to come in and
make out obviously I'm like yeah ah
you're really pretty I want to press my
face to yours but then when we got there
we both just sat on the couch and she
talked till like 3:00 a.m. and I was
like yo girl I'm gonna wake up at like
6:00 a.m. I was told there would be
kisses here there are no kisses and like
look I don't want to sound like an
[ __ ] like I don't mind talking I love
talking but she could have said do you
wanna come in and just talk and I would
have had totally different expectations
for the evening you know finally I
started falling asleep and I was like
hey I gotta go and I gave her one kiss
and and left and I felt sad that the
amount of kisses promised did not equal
the amount of kisses delivered and once
again
I felt like a dude who was upset that I
did not receive the expected physical
kisses I was promised
you're a Weinstein apologist and that's
it you're just wine thin right now you
were that she can change her mind she
said that at the doorstep and when she
was inside she felt like talking hey
you're just a creep and a bad person and
you should be canceled of course I'm
kidding but that's the [ __ ] I hear what
you said it was pretty problematic by
your standards was it misleading yeah
but as you know they can withdraw their
consent and their interest and their
affection at any point and that's what
it means to my god to say about that no
move on look move the heck on I felt
like a loser
hey no girl you felt like a girl because
it's not a dude thing if I tell you
something that's misleading and I
changed my mind whether you're a dude or
girl it's not a I felt like I dunno you
felt like yourself in that position
that's it it's not a dude thing it's not
a woman thing
it's people think and I wanted to talk
about this because I felt like this has
really been expanding my perspective
when it comes to dating I finally
understand a lot of the complaints my
male friends have about dating that I
admit I would usually dismiss but now I
really get it when they say dating is
just so expensive man sometimes I feel
like that girl doesn't even like me for
me she just wants like a boyfriend I
wish it were more socially expected to
go dutch on the first few dates but
you're like a jerk if you even suggest
it and any experience that expands your
compassion and understanding is one that
I think is worthy of sharing so what
about you have you had any experiences
that have shifted your viewpoint
dramatically thank you I guess
cuz you understand us but at the same
time you need it absolutely to be in the
position to understand when were asked
to not know and we have to understand or
else for church we have to not be in
your space not be in your position and
we have to understand what's going on
we cannot refute what you're saying ever
but you can the only way you were able
to understand us was if you were in our
shoes huh that's weird because when we
don't understand something we just
automatically viewed as a church you
dismiss the point of a man when he was
telling you all this things just opening
up to you and you just decided to
dismiss them but you're able to do that
you you always okay if you do it it's
alright
it's not a problem same thing like I
hear that often like I'm talking with
something I'm talking with some people
and girls and whenever I express my side
yeah but you know I'm trying to have a
conversation because the conversation is
you need two people talking to
viewpoints we don't have to agree but at
least I mean like let me just expand on
what I'm saying I'm expanding on what
I'm trying to say them on my viewpoint
and like boohoo
you just debate dismissal is very quick
I'm being dismissed not by an argument
or a counter argument I'm busy being
dismissed just because I don't agree
with you because you don't see my
viewpoint but I'm asking Sicily to just
know what you should know what you what
I'm feeling because you but but you you
get you have to be absolutely in my
pants everybody got their privilege well
guess what every other aspect have
different privileges they're not the
same they're not necessarily equal but
everybody got their privileges right now
you have the privilege to dismiss people
and it's gonna be fine
you're not gonna be viewed as a jerk
you're gonna be just fine mmm oh I
understand that you know your viewpoint
as women were being dismissed for years
and years and years and years but the
solution to that is not the opposite
example do you the solution to racism is
not more racism the solution to sexism
is not fix ISM the resolution from you
being dismissed is not you dismissing
other people hmm
you have to be able to hmm view the
other person's perspective and listen to
them sympathize if you will we don't
require your empathy sympathy is good
enough just understand and it's fine we
working at it but a lot of you aren't
and so I feel really I have like mixed
feelings about this video because on one
side I'm like yeah thank you very much
for sharing your experience of our
experience so more people may listen to
you I guess but on the other hand I'm
like you really needed to do that thanks
but no thanks what do you think cuz
you're the one dating I don't have pots
oddly enough I just looked at it I was
like okay it's interesting
my thoughts are hmm you know you don't
have anything not really darling I was
like two sitting back here now she's
listening outside man yeah my thoughts
are dissent thank you but
okay please if you're gonna get ready
get ready for you don't make us pay
don't make us accountable your grooming
has nothing to do with us that's your
responsibility and for you to pay for
all right because if I'm paying for this
meal because you look good we're edging
towards that's work so just fine just
call it that just call it that
and we're gonna be under standard of
that oh that's what it is
yeah I'm paying for that I'm not just
paying for the mill I'm paying for your
meal just for you to look good but I
paid to have someone that looked good
and if it's that then let it be on the
basis of that because that's what this
order yes yeah you don't listen you pay
for the companionship yeah you don't
listen sleep with a person which is fine
we just find it you do you think it's
fine but if you want to classify as that
then fine don't be a hypocrite about it
she want to want to have that you can't
do things like that go about this and
this workers on the side well I'm not
like that a girl but you just to get all
right so that's it for today's we don't
let us know what you think
[Music]